hello guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan cyber
five nights at freddies world teaser
trailer gameplay oh thank god
I was really worried there wasn't be
more five nights ah he'll be sarcastic
you [ __ ] oh this is gonna be
different I hope you're ready to uh get
the [ __ ] scared out of you because this
one is ten times scarier than the
previous one
chikka always kind of
this is you know
what yeah what the [ __ ] the next five
nights is a RPG featuring all of the
characters from five nights at Freddy's
as playable characters as you take on
whatever evil things coming at you bruh
wait this is real yes totally real how
do you know because I have been checking
his site on the rig to make sure he
wasn't gonna throw some weird five
nights five at me I have to be aware of
what Scott is doing at all times as a
gaming channel just in case he does
something how do you feel about that I
mean he's done RPGs in the past but um
yeah she has Dan yes he has I'm really
interested I mean like if it's a good
game that's good game and what can you
say but like other than that
five nights is what made him he knows
what's gonna sell again but am I gonna
get it what probably not that's a
totally different audience what well
yeah I mean obviously like this isn't
going to be the viral hit that everyone
is expecting because this I don't know
it's like it seems like it's just a fun
game joke for people who are fans of
five nights at Freddy's yeah it's better
be a one-time thing yeah I think it's a
lot of things you know I think it's him
wanting to break away from horror that
his other games aren't even remotely
close to horror
it's about transitioning than not about
hey let's make a leap do you remember
when Robert Pattinson did Twilight and
then he did a movie called remember me
no exactly my pen ha ha it was too big
of a leap I know like dude I get it I
get it but I understand what Scott's
trying to do I just think he's done it a
little too late after four horror games
within a year becoming one the biggest
viral potentials and then immediately
switching over to an RPG is it the
smartest move I don't know but like he's
a developer and he can do what he wants
and make what he wants and if he wants
to make it RPG I support I don't know if
I'll play it but
I'll support the hell out of them you
just you just want to make everyone
happy don't you oh like I mean that's
because you don't want it you don't want
a sigh Dan alright there's no gray in
life it's only black and white that's
total [ __ ] no that is complete and
utter [ __ ] that's a quote we like a
world of shades of gray 50 of them come
on you see what I did there
yeah that was you see what I did dad
come on I did it you I did you I did it
him leave leave it to the pros I mean
here's the thing if he makes a legit
good RPG then more power to him true
that's true I mean I'll give it a shot
I definitely don't care to go out of my
way mm-hmm if like someone's like hey
man let's play this and I'm like I'm not
really wanna play he's like come on
let's just try it really can we smoke
some weed first sure you can smoke some
we all want some weed imagine it's you
and I have this family and then I
finally agreed a plate and who knows it
might be a fun time but I'm not like so
invested in five nights at Freddy's
story and characters to the point where
I like I want to play this new version
of them the thing with five nights is
it's the lore that sells the game and I
feel like when you just take all that
make them cute put them in an RPG you
can't make as rich of a lore it'll be
really interesting to see what happens
yeah yeah because I'm not I don't really
follow the storyline of five nights but
I know fans of five nights really are
addicted to that storyline it's only
condyloid confusing I could see from a
perspective of that kind of fan how they
would be on board for this because they
just like the journey of like the
animatronics and stuff yeah sure give it
to you give it to you see well run
reviews come out I'll decide whether I'm
gonna do it anyway [ __ ] and hoes
subscribe today by clicking this button
yeah yeah become a rejected gangster did
you feel did you feel you had to go thug
because we just watched probably the
cutest weirdest thing no no I don't feel
the need to make up well you know some
false masculinity and you can join the
cybernaut today by clicking a subscribe
button for me yeah
didn't give you a chance
the [ __ ] now no one's gonna follow you
Frank Ramos hook it up with a shout-out
where our videos every day hoping to see
you videos videos are dope ass hell
don't breath hell
he said dope ass hell I'm I'm assuming
that's dope as hell I know but what if
he meant dope ass huh you know that
makes me think of yay dope he'll fire up
the dope in someone's ass that sounds
like a really bad drink Ramos wants me
to lie to join in his battle
are you going to do it depends on how
veronica feels about it
Veronica yes may I light a joint up
Frank Ron OSes button yes hmm
as long as we love one another we can do
whatever we want how do you guys
function a lot of suppression a lot of
suppression walker pent up a lot of
bent-up resentment and unspoken dialogue
that really needs to be out there